here's something interesting last week I
told you about Republican governor from
Ohio Mike DeWine who essentially
abandoned Donald Trump when it comes to
dealing with coronavirus Mike DeWine
took coronavirus seriously from quite
early on one of the one of the earlier
governors to really take action and he
has seen his approval skyrocket thanks
to not following the Trump doctrine and
following the sort of sensible governor
doctrine on coronavirus we've now
learned that Republican Congressman
Peter King from New York who I am no big
fan of is going to be ignoring the
Republican Party and voting for a
democratic coronavirus relief package
that's expected to be voted on later
today if it may already have been voted
on by the time you listen to today's
show now I have mixed feelings about
this in the sense that it is once again
it's a Republican who's personally
affected by something and now is
behaving rationally and doing the right
and pathetic thing I wish it didn't take
that to get them to behave appropriately
and what I mean by that is Peter King is
a New York congressman he represents one
of the hardest hit areas by the virus
it's New York's second congressional
district this is the South Shore of Long
Island so it's not the absolute
epicenter of New York City's five
boroughs but it's as close as you can be
it's it's Juneau the New York City metro
area without actually being there and
that's why he's going to vote in favor
of this package Republicans have been
talking more and more about what if we
maybe limit relief to blue states
they've been hesitant to do more relief
and a second stimulus but Peter King
can't get away with that his district
has been absolutely crushed so there are
some who are framing this as hero Peter
King abandons his party and does the
right thing well it's more like Peter
King abandons his party on this one bill
because it would be political suicide
for him personally not to since he
represents one of the hardest-hit
congressional districts in the country
if it were the Boston area or Seattle
that needed this particular type of bill
and not his district my guess is he
would not be voting for it he would
simply stick it out with Republicans
Peter King is normally no friend of the
left or of the Democratic Party
and this is one it's it's a horrible
realization that we have to have what it
takes for some of these people to do
something to do the right thing is to be
personally affected he needs to be
reelected in November so that's why he
has to do this now as far as the bill
goes there are actually some really
interesting things in it this is called
the heroes Act three trillion in total
it stands for the health and economic
recovery omnibus emergency solutions Act
heroes Act it would pay a company's
payroll costs up to $100,000 per
employee who has been laid off or
furloughed if the business can
demonstrate that their revenue has
dropped at least 20 percent um it would
add eight hundred and fifty billion in
assistance to state and local
governments 200 billion in hazard pay
for frontline health care workers and
other non-essential workers it would do
another round of 1200 dollar checks to
most Americans it would raise the
payment per child from five hundred
dollars also to twelve hundred dollars
but it would be capped total at six
thousand dollars per family it would
extend the Supplemental or I guess
they're calling it enhanced unemployment
from the federal government through
January 31st of next year and one of the
most interesting components that's
buried in there which I don't actually
think will pass if the bill does pass is
that it will eliminate the ten thousand
dollar cap on what's called salt state
and local taxes for 2020 and 2021 this
is super interesting because one of the
ways that the Trump Republican tax
reform of 2017 hurt those in states like
mostly blue tip blue states with higher
state income taxes is they limited the
state and local tax deduction to ten
thousand dollars so if you live in a
very high tax state or just a blue state
with a reasonable amount of tax you are
limited in what amount of tax you can
write off on your federal return to ten
thousand dollars total this goes
directly at blue states and it tends to
have no effect in some of these red
states that have no state income tax so
it would repeal that for 2020 and
21 which is very very interesting
although analysts agree it is very
unlikely that that suspension of the
$10,000 salt cap would actually make it
into a final bill that passes Senate and
House Conference but in the meantime we
will see how the House votes Peter King
apparently will be voting with Democrats
and we will follow it